starting over getting back on track from
drew let's see what drew's got here for
us starting over
all right you're starting over on what
bro
um let's go actually uh
what's going on is um i got once i'm
necessarily starting over but i'm kind
of at a point where
i
feel like i'm stuck and so i'm trying to
find i guess some things that i can do
that can
start making me like better income
um
i mean i've never really had a problem
with getting girls i've never had a
problem you know with working out i'm
actually gonna head to the gym here in
like 30 minutes but
um
what do you do for work right now
huh what do you do for work right now
um i have i have two jobs actually i
work i work at a warehouse um unloading
planes for fedex
and then also um i deliver and install
appliances for a company mm-hmm okay
all right so what's the ask are you
looking for a side hustle you're looking
for something new
yeah i guess yeah i guess just some i
guess some
some high income skills i could learn to
start possibly making into the six
figures because i've read your book and
i always hear you know
the one thing that kind of stuck with me
was when you said um
that uh
most um most alpha men um are trying to
get to a seven figure income or you know
build seven figures of wealth and i feel
like i'm
you know i'm doing okay for where i live
at and i'm probably probably about 50
000 a year but i would like to start
making it to the six figures possibly
all right and how old are you right now
i know i'm 33 and where do you live
i'm in texas all right so
yeah i mean
one of the concepts that i'm building on
with my second book you know the
follow-up to the first book is gonna
deal with the wealth creation aspect
um
if you if you want to have autonomy over
yourself if you want to have the ability
to have
you know say no to people and events and
and offers and jobs and gigs money is a
big part of that um there's a reason why
they call it fu money
um you're generally not gonna make it
work for somebody else it's it's unless
you're in a field like high ticket sales
like you're selling yachts or
rolls-royces or mclarens
um you're generally not going to get
into bank there
unless you're like a lawyer
that has a very high billable rate with
a number of years behind you you
specialize in a highly profitable field
i was at this lawyer's house a few years
ago on a rally down in the states i
think it was near st louis and
and his and his underlying name was the
uh ferrari collector and he was a
i think he was a
mesothelioma lawyer
um that did class action lawsuits so you
make serious money this guy had a
mansion with like 30 ferraris um you can
make serious money you know in high
level areas like that
ceos cfos ctos my personal favorite is
entrepreneurship
the barrier to entry like nobody can say
no to you
but
the market will say no to you if you
suck so if you don't have something
that's worth people buying that solve
serious problems in their lives that's
scalable that you have control of you're
never gonna make money at it and most
and most people fail at it you know like
nine out of ten times you know you are
going to fail so
you've got something going on right now
my recommendation would be to kind of
like look around
maybe there's something in your industry
as you're going about your day-to-day
activities that's problematic that's a
bottleneck that's um that you see a
solution to the problem or maybe you
know another industry that you've kind
of tripped across you can take it from
there and apply it to that industry it's
got it's basically called rip off and
duplicate like r d doesn't stand for
research and development rip off and
duplicate is how most entrepreneurs
become successful so just start looking
around you know use your eyesight use
your vision and see what see what
opportunities lie around you that you
could potentially tap into and then
offer the solution then to the
marketplace and then let it decide if it
really wants and if it's willing to give
you it's it's harder money and wealth
it's a lot easier for me to say it than
it is to execute on it and most people
do fail at it but how do you begin you
just begin another
piece of advice that i'd give you drew
is i'd say study greatness
so read biographies of successful
entrepreneurs
read the everything store which is on
jeff bezos read losing my virginity
which is on richard branson read um for
mindset uh something like maximum
achievement by brian tracy um again
success leaves clues so i mean if you're
driving or you're working a warehouse
and you can put earbuds in just get the
audio book and listen to it while you're
working you know like put in one earbud
and just listen you know while you're
working there's different ways to go
about it but just begin you know
basically what i'm saying with that
does that make sense yeah i understand
next time i've i've been i've been
trying to get into real estate investing
so i've been reading up on that also but
yeah i was just i was just wondering now
so
texas is a really big real estate market
if you like um you know if you live in
texas and you like real real estate uh
my good friend jason bible which is on
my uh one percent shows and we usually
do these the first monday of every month
on the unplugged alpha podcast he's one
of the guys that pops in he's big in
texas real estate he has a book on
amazon called mr texas real estate
i would check that out
okay i do that thank you all right bro
you